The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so today we're
going to think about
the-- well, also
the low end of the
polynomial hierarchy.
So most of this class
is about polynomial
versus not polynomial and
various notions of hardness,
[? NP ?] hardness, and worse.
We look briefly at
P-completeness, which
is about parallel computing.
Today we're going to be
thinking about regular good old
sequential computing, but trying
to distinguish linear time
versus non-linear time,
and in particular,
trying to find problems
that are quadratic
or cubic in n for
sequential running times.
And probably the most
popular attack on this
is called 3SUM, which is
the following problem.
You're given n integers.
Let's say, and you want to know
do any three of them sum to 0?
So of course, you can
solve this in cubic time
by testing all triples,
whether they sum to 0.
But you can also solve
it in quadratic time.
So it's not an algorithms class.
I won't ask you to
come up the algorithm.
But they're quite easy.
First order n squared
randomized is really easy.
You take all pairwise sums.
So first of all you, build
a dictionary, a hash table
of all the integers.
And then you look at
all pairwise sums.
For each pairwise sum, you
see whether the negation
is in the hash table
in constant time.
So that gives you n
squared randomized,
because if a plus
b plus c equals 0
is the same thing as a
plus b equal minus c.
So you look at
all pairwise sums,
see whether the negation
is in the list of integers.
OK, you can also do order
n squared deterministic.
This a more fun puzzle.
But I'll spoil
the answer for you
just to give you intuition for
why this problem is n squared.
For every possible
target sum minus c--
so that's going to
happen n times--
I'm going to run the following
linear time algorithm.
So this is just two copies of
the integers in sorted order.
I have n log n time to sort.
So that's no problem.
I'm going to start from
with my left finger
here and my right
finger here and look
at the sum of those two numbers.
If it's too big-- I have a
particular targets, negative c,
in mind-- if the sum
of these two numbers
is smaller then negative c, then
I'm going to advance this one,
because if this is
in sorted order that
will make my sum larger.
If the sum is too big, I will
advance this one backwards.
So in general, I have my
right finger advancing
left or my left finger
advancing right.
In each step, one
of the two advances.
And this will not miss--
and this will tell you
whether that target sum
is among the pairwise sums
from this thing.
In linear time, we
do that n times, once
for each target sum.
So that's the fancy
quadratic algorithm.
No fancy data
structures required.
Cool.
So 3SUM is quadratic.
And the big conjecture is that
you can't solve it any faster.
Well, you can.
So it's not quite
the conjecture.
The conjecture is that there
is no n to the 2 minus epsilon
algorithm in general--
in the worst case.
Let me tell you before
we get to-- and this is
has led to a whole world of
lower bounds of 3SUM hardness.
If your problem is
3SUM hard, then you
expect it also has no n to
the 2 minus epsilon algorithm,
because if it did, 3SUM would.
And people generally believe
that's the case for 3SUM.
But there are some exceptions.
So one thing is that the
numbers have to be fairly large.
If all of the integers are
in the range, let's say,
minus u to u-- that's the
universe size-- then via FFT,
you can solve the problem in
u log u time plus linear time.
So your numbers better be at
least larger than n squared.
And in fact, we'll
see n cube suffices.
So they don't have
to be huge, but they
do have to be bigger
than linear or quadratic.
More generally,
there are a bunch
of sub-quadratic, but only
slightly sub-quadratic,
algorithms.
The first one achieves a
roughly log squared savings.
So a little bit less is a log
log squared in the denominator.
This is a randomized algorithm
in a model of computation
called the word RAM.
So if you're interested
in the word RAM,
you should take advanced
data structures.
But basically you can
manipulate, let's say,
log n bit words
in constant time.
You can add them
together, multiply them,
that sort of thing.
And you assume that
the numbers you're
dealing with fit in a word.
Because if you're
going to compare them,
you'd also need that assumption.
So that's a reasonable model.
And it essentially affords
a kind of logarithmic amount
of parallelism.
And so because it's a quadratic
problem, roughly speaking
you get a quadratic amount in
the parallelism of the model.
So it's a bit improved.
This is by two former MIT
students, [? Eli ?] Barron
and Mihai Petrescu and myself.
And very recently,
this year, there's
been another nice improvement.
It's actually three algorithms,
depending on your model.
But all based on a similar idea.
Did I get these backwards?
I think so.
So first, these two
results-- so these
are results by
[? Gourmand ?] and Petty.
So that's Petty, gave a
talk here about it recently.
In a real RAM model
of computation--
this is a weaker
model of computation,
so the result is stronger.
In a real RAM, you still assume
the numbers you're given,
you can add them.
I think actually all
it needs is the ability
to add them and compare them,
maybe subtract-- yeah, also
subtract.
But no multiplication
is really useful
in that particular model.
Because you can't extract
bits out of the thing,
so you don't assume
that they're integers,
you just treat them
as real numbers.
And all you know how to
do is add a bunch of them
and compare those additions.
So that's a weaker
model of computation.
And still they're able to
get a roughly logarithmic
improvement, not quite as
strong as the quadratic analog.
But one advance is that this
is the first deterministic
algorithm to be n squared.
So randomization isn't
necessary to achieve that.
Though this is 2/3 power.
But the other
advance is that you
don't need to manipulate
the individual bits.
So even in the randomized
model that's nice.
And then the major thing,
and sort of the first thing
to call into question the
3SUM conjecture, which
is that conjecture,
is I wouldn't really
call this an algorithm.
But it's a thing which runs
n roughly n to the 1.5 time.
But here it's a more powerful
model, a super powerful model,
called the decision
tree model, where
the idea is that an algorithm
is specified by an entire tree.
The depth of the
tree is this big.
Each node of the tree says,
add these five things,
compare them to
these five things,
and see which is
bigger, and then branch.
There's a left branch,
and a right tree.
If you've ever seen a
comparison tree, same thing.
But the comparisons
are more interesting.
But this is not an
algorithm, because we
don't know how to compute
that tree efficiently.
We can compute it in
probably polynomial time,
but we don't know how to
compute it in sub-quadratic time
or sub-this time.
So it's kind of a
frustrating situation,
because we know
that this thing is
sort of out there, but
actually finding it is hard.
And actually several problems
in computers since the '80s,
I think, where we know
better decision trees
than we know algorithms.
So my sense would be that
decision tree model is strictly
more powerful.
The 3SUM conjecture is
true for regular algorithms
if you define it
this way or this way.
But in the decision to
model, obviously, you
can do a lot better.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What's the reason
to believe the decision tree
model is some bit that we
run polynomial algorithm,
look at the bit and it
tells us the incident?
PROFESSOR: You mean, why would--
AUDIENCE: Why would you believe
this decision tree is there,
like a model of computation
that we should care about?
PROFESSOR: Oh,
no, you shouldn't.
Decision tree is not
a model you should
consider a reasonable computer.
But it's interesting in that
it suggests-- it gives you
this tantalizing
feeling that maybe you
could turn this into
a real algorithm,
you could run a computer.
But, definitely,
yeah, you cannot--
if you don't know what decision
tree is you can't run it
on a computer directly.
So it's not a model
of computation
in the strict sense.
It's especially
interesting-- I mean,
it's always important to see
how the model of competition
relates to bounds,
particularly if you're
going to try to prove
the lower bound.
There are some lower bounds of
n squared in restricted forms
of the decision tree model.
This says you can't
extend those lower bounds
to arbitrary decision trees.
Decision trees are traditionally
used as a lower bound model.
If you can prove a
lower bound there,
because it's a very
powerful model,
that implies lower bounds in
something like the real RAM.
So that's why people
care in some sense.
This says you can't
prove a strong lower
bound in that model,
which is annoying.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: What is
the tree that they
found the structure and
the constants of the nodes,
does it depend on the
values of the integer?
Only the number?
PROFESSOR: I'm pretty
sure in this model
you have a constant number
of original integers.
You add them together
and compare them
to a constant number
of original integers.
AUDIENCE: But what
was is-- I mean
I can compute the tree in sum,
but what does it depend on?
Like if I change the value--
PROFESSOR: The tree, of
course, has exponential size.
So you never would actually
want to compute it explicitly.
What you want to
compute is after I've
done some number of things,
what's the next operation that
happens.
AUDIENCE: That's
still not my question.
So my question is what
changes the actual structure
of the tree?
Is it just the number--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, n.
The decision tree
only depends on n.
I mean in some sense the
decision tree's encoding
an adaptive algorithm,
that depending
on the results of
previous comparisons
tells you what to do next about.
If you think of it
as the entire tree
that's only depending on n.
But because it's so big, I
mean, that doesn't help us if.
You could imagine
pre-computing for n,
but there's no way to store it.
And you couldn't really
afford that exponential time.
OK, so that's a short story
about the known upper bounds
and also the known
lower bounds on 3SUM.
There are some weak lower
bounds in a particular version
of the decision tree
model when you can only
compare I think
sums of two items,
then you can get an n
squared lower bound.
But that's not
especially interesting
given this result anymore.
Let me tell you briefly
about k sum, which
is the obvious generalization,
instead of 3, do any k of them
sum to 0?
Here, they're actually
stronger and lower bounds.
So if 3SUM is the most
popular thing considered
for proving quadratic
lower bounds,
because a lot of
problems we care
about are linear or
quadratic, so 3SUM
gets a lot of the attention.
K sum is a little
easier to argue about.
In particular, it's NP
hard in general, right.
This, in particular, encodes
something like partition.
If you have n integers, and
they're overall sum is 0,
and you want to know
whether any n/2 of them
sum to 0 or something
like that, that
would be roughly partition.
So this is NP hard.
So definitely it's got
to get hard for some k.
In fact, you can show
fixed parameter hardness,
W1 hardness, with respect to k.
So in particular, if you
assume the exponential time
hypothesis, then you
get some lower bounds.
And the best lower
bound known so far
is that there's no n to
the little of k algorithm,
assuming regular ETH.
For this, we need to assume k is
less than or equal to-- is not
too giant, because, I guess,
if k equals n, for example,
this problem is really easy.
So it can't go all the way.
So this says, well, maybe we
don't get the constant right,
but there's some kind of n
to the roughly k dependence.
So there's a reason that there's
a number here larger than 1.
Although we don't know how
to prove that, the feeling is
that 3SUM, k sum,
they require roughly n
to some constant times k.
You can debate about
what the constant is,
but we have this theorem.
And on the upper bound side--
and what people believe
is the right answer-- is k/2
ceiling-- at least randomized.
If you want deterministic,
you might get a log factor.
But you can definitely
achieve this
by the same kind of do all
k/2y sums twice, and then
look for collisions
in the hash table.
And so the ceiling
is what's making 3SUM
into a quadratic thing.
But 4 sum is just
as easy as 3SUM,
because you can still
solve it in quadratic time.
But 5 sum, the conjecture is
that requires n cube time.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
didn't quite catch that.
Is that a known result?
PROFESSOR: This is an
upper bound is known.
And then the conjecture
is that that's tight.
There's no end to the ceiling
k/2 minus epsilon algorithm.
That's what we don't know.
But algorithm is easy.
So that's k sum.
And this gives you
some more intuition
for why you should expect
these problems are hard.
In particular, if you could
prove k sum requires-- I mean,
if you can prove
this conjecture,
you prove the exponential
time hypothesis.
So you prove p
does not equal NP.
And you may make $1 million
and lots of good things happen.
So we should try to do this.
Of course, as I
mentioned, 3SUM is the one
we use the most in this world,
because for NP hard problems,
usually we use NP hardness
and all the stuff we did.
You could use k sum, but
that's basically partition.
But this is sort of
motivation for why
you should think 3SUM is hard.
I'll leave it at that.
So let me talk
about 3SUM hardness.
So I'm going to call a problem
3SUM hard if that algorithm has
an n to the two minus epsilon
time algorithm, then so
does 3SUM.
OK, this is what we want.
If I say problem
is 3SUM is hard,
it means it shouldn't
be solvable in less
than quadratic time other
than this poly log stuff.
So this is the formal meaning.
If you could solve it
in sub-quadratic, truly
sub-quadratic time this is
often called the minus epsilon,
then 3SUM can be solved in
truly sub-quadratic time,
contradicting the
3SUM conjecture.
So if you believe this is the
3SUM conjecture that means
this is not possible
for your problem.
And the way we're going
to do that usually
is with a 3SUM reduction.
There are other ways to do it.
You don't have to follow this
particular style reduction.
But most of them do.
So it's going to be a multi call
reduction, but in this world,
we have to be careful
about polynomial factors.
We don't want to call
your thing n times
and say that was a
legitimate reduction.
So let's say you can call--
if you're reducing from a to
b, then that means you
could solve b using a.
And you're going to make a
constant number of calls to a.
Sorry, other way around.
That means I can
solve a using b.
Usually, we take
an instance here,
reduce it to an instance here.
That's OK.
But because we're going to
want to solve not just decision
problems, we're
going to say, OK,
you take your instance of a.
You can call an
oracle for solving
b a constant number of times,
as long as the thing you call it
with is also not much bigger.
So the n prime that you
call this thing with
should be linear in n.
And the running time
of the reduction
should be sub-quadratic.
OK, pretty much all
reductions, it's like n,
n log n, maybe n log squared n.
But it should be strictly
less than n squared,
otherwise the reduction doesn't
tell you much about weather
the problem is quadratic or not.
So with this much
running time, plausibly
you could construct
a larger instance.
But this constraint
says the instance
of b that you called
should be linear in size,
so the quadratic over
here is the same thing
as quadratic over here.
OK, so those are the
rules of the game.
We're not going to have to
worry about these constraints
too much.
Most of our reductions are
constant factor blow up and run
in a reasonable amount
of time, But we've
got to be a little
careful here to make
sure the running
time is not huge.
Usually we're allowed
polynomial time.
OK, so if you have a 3SUM
reduction from a to b,
and you know a is 3SUM
hard, then b is 3SUM hard.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: N prime is the
size of the thing that
you're-- the instance
you're calling with.
So if you have an
instance x over here,
you have some x prime over here.
N prime is the size of x prime.
There's a constant
number of them.
But I want all of those
instances to be linear size.
OK, so initially a
is going to be 3SUM.
3SUM is 3SUM hard.
Because if it as a sub-quadratic
algorithm, then so does itself.
And so that's actually easy.
NP harnessed,
that's not so easy.
If we let b be
some other problem,
then we'll prove hardness.
In this world, because we
don't have any solid, lower
bounds to work from, it's
also interesting to go
in both directions.
I'm not going to define
a notion of completeness
here, just because
it hasn't been done.
But you could define
3SUM completeness
to mean you can reduce from
3SUM and you can reduce to 3SUM.
We'll see a few problems
in that-- usually people
call that equivalence,
sub-quadratic equivalence.
OK, so let me start with
some base 3SUM hard problems
to start from.
A lot of this comes
from a paper--
this paper-- by Gajentaan
and Overmars, 1995.
And they had been
collecting over the years
a whole bunch of mostly
computational geometry
problems, which are 3SUM hard
in that you can reduce 3SUM
to all of them.
But in the center here is a
bunch of core problems, 3SUM,
3SUM prime, which I would
call ABC version of 3SUM--
we've seen a few ABC
problems in the past--
and a geometric version of 3SUM.
So let me tell you about those.
First of all, 3SUM is 3SUM hard,
even when u is order n cubed.
So that's nice to know.
The integers you're working
with don't have to be giant.
This is based on a
hashing argument,
which we won't go into.
OK, so what is 3SUM prime?
3SUM prime you're given three
sets of integers, A, B, C--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: For these
reductions we're
using only deterministic
reductions?
PROFESSOR: Let's say we're only
using deterministic reductions,
although randomized would
also be interesting,
You just have to
weaken this statement.
But here I'll say deterministic.
AUDIENCE: Is the hashing
argument for why [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'm pretty
sure you can derandomize
that hashing scheme.
I need to double check,
but, yeah, that's the claim.
Yeah, that is good question.
So this is the ABC
version of 3SUM.
We just want the
three items to come
from three particular sets.
And traditionally,
this one is phrased
as a plus b equals c,
although you could also
say a plus b plus c equals 0.
It's the same thing.
You're just negating
all the c's.
And in this world, because you
have one item from each set,
actually it's really easy to
just negate one subset of them.
So it doesn't matter whether you
put a minus sign here or not.
But I will not, because that's
how 3SUM prime is usually
defined.
So I claim 3SUM
prime is 3SUM hard.
Why?
I let capital A-- if I'm
given a 3SUM instance,
let's call it S. S is
a set of n integers.
I'm going to let a
equal S. I'm going
to let b equal S. I'm going
to let c equal negative s.
Done.
OK, so that's a
reduction from 3SUM.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like if 0 is in your list,
the way the instance
you constructed,
you might use some element
x of the list from a.
The same element x from
b, and then y from c.
And x plus x might be, I
guess, plus y would equal 0.
In the original list
you didn't have x twice.
I'm just getting the
example of choosing 0 three
times as sort of a
convenient example of that.
PROFESSOR: So that you
also detect a linear time.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean?
PROFESSOR: You can
detect whether there
are any such triples.
If you allow repetition,
then you answer the question.
Your goal is to solve 3SUM.
AUDIENCE: So you're
solving 3SUM by making
oracle calls to 3SUM prime?
PROFESSOR: Right, so if
you can 3SUM ahead of time,
you're done.
In linear time, you
can check whether there
are any pairs that allow,
with some duplication,
a solution to 3SUM instance.
This is not addressed
in the paper, which
makes me think that in
this definition of 3SUM,
we allow the items
to-- basically,
every item could be used three
times, up to three times.
There's no requirement that
they're distinct items.
So then this reduction is fine.
I don't think that's a big deal.
And you can get rid of it.
But that must be how
it's normally defined.
I didn't specify whether it
was three distinct items.
But let's allow
multiplicity there.
And then this reduction
is fine, because that's
what the paper does.
OK, with more effort, like
adding big integers and so on,
you can reduce-- in
the other direction
reduce from 3SUM prime to 3SUM.
I won't cover that,
because I just
want to prove the 3SUM
hardness about things.
But in fact, all
these three problems
are identical to each other.
If any one of them
is sub-quadratic,
then they all are.
So that's nice, because
3SUM prime is really
a special case of 3SUM.
So our next problem is
the geometric problem.
They call it geometric
base problem.
So here we're in 2D.
And we're given endpoints
whose y-coordinates are all
0, 1, or 2.
You can imagine why--
because there's three lists.
And so they all live on
three horizontal lines.
Here are the points.
And we want to know is there a
non-horizontal line that passes
through three points like this.
OK, so our claim,
GeomBase is 3SUM hard.
And this is their proof.
On the first line, we put A.
On the last line, we put B.
And in the middle line, we put
every item in C divided by 2.
So if you look at-- sorry, this
is a reduction from 3SUM prime.
So I have three integers.
We want to know whether you
can every a plus b equals c.
So the idea is if I
have two items, A and B,
then this point-- I mean,
if I just draw the line
and intersect it with
the y' equals 1 line,
that point will be the
average of little a and little
b-- so a plus b over 2.
So if there's an item C
that matches a plus b,
then the C/2 will equal
the a plus b over 2.
So there's going to be a
line through three points,
if and only if, 3SUM
prime had a yes answer.
And you can reduce in the
reverse direction-- in fact,
just like this.
You just multiply all
these coordinates by 2.
That gives you C.
So those are our
starting points.
And we're going to
use all of them.
And I'm just going to run
through a bunch of examples
of 3SUM hard problems.
So all of them shouldn't have
sub-quadratic time algorithms
unless 3SUM does.
So the obvious
starting point here
is what's called
degeneracy testing
in computational geometry.
So usually, we like
to assume that you
have endpoints in the plane.
They're in general position,
meaning no three are co-linear.
So the problem is
given endpoints,
are any three of them co-linear?
Question?
AUDIENCE: With 3SUM prime,
because those are integers,
how do you deal
with them that way?
PROFESSOR: Oh, integers
and rational, same thing,
you just scale it, multiply.
So everything
here-- because we're
going to go into
geometry quite, I
will use rationals quite a bit.
So I can multiply everything
by 2 to make it integers again.
But this problem does
not say integers,
so that's why I'm
allowed to do that.
I start with integers.
And then I do this.
But you can also
add integers here.
It wouldn't make
a big difference.
OK, so given endpoints in the
plane, are any three co-linear?
I'm guessing this is
the original motivation
for defining 3SUM.
This is really a harder
version of the problem.
This is kind of a special case.
But in particular, it's
not exactly the same,
because we forbid
horizontal lines.
We had to construct a
very degenerate instance
with lots of points on the
horizontal lines in order
for this correspondence to work.
So the question is
can you make something
that is only degenerate,
only has three points
co-linear, when the 3SUM
instance has a solution?
And this reduction is
a little unsatisfying.
And I don't have a
great intuition for it.
But it's very simple.
We're going to
take-- this is going
to be a reduction from regular
old 3SUM, not 3SUM prime.
So every number x, we're going
to map to the point x comma
x cubed.
Cubed because it's odd
and not 1 basically.
And so we take our x values--
probably not a good idea
to put 0 in there, but whatever.
And we just project them onto
this x cubed curve, x 3 is odd,
so it has this nice picture.
And the claim is if you take
any two points here-- so
here's an x-coordinate 1/4
and 3/4, and, of course,
they would actually be integers.
That's OK.
You can scale.
Then so the sum of those is 1.
And if you look at
negative 1, that will--
the cube of negative
1, which is 1,
is exactly equal to where
these two cubed points would
hit if you extend the line.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Now we
have the problem
that if you want to use
the version of 3SUM here,
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep, so
we definitely need
that those guys are distinct.
I'm sure that those
two versions of 3SUM
are equivalent up to
sub-quadratic reductions.
But I don't see how to
prove that off hand.
OK, cool, now why is this true?
I've checked it.
It's true.
Off the page of a
algebra and prove it.
I don't have a great intuition
for why this is true.
But there you go.
It's easy enough to check
where this line should go.
And it happens to go exactly to
the place where the sum goes.
So sorry.
I'm guessing it would also
work for x to the fifth.
But I didn't check that.
OK so those three
points on the line.
OK, so an important life
lesson about geometry
is something called duality.
So here we're interested
whether there was one line that
goes through three points.
A complimentary problem is
I give you a bunch of lines,
do any three of them pass
through a common point?
Is there one intersection
between three or more lines?
Is there a point that
is on three lines?
If you know projective geometry,
this is totally obvious.
It's the same problem as this.
You just apply duality.
Now, there are many
different dualities.
I'll give you two today.
First, my favorite
is projected duality
and the sort of most
standard, at least, in math.
If you have a point with
x-coordinate a and y-coordinate
b, you map that to the line
ax plus by plus 1 equals 0.
And vice versa.
So if I have a line--
almost every line
can be written this way.
Everyone line that does
not go through the origin
can be written like this.
And then you can convert it
into the corresponding point.
So if you give me
a bunch of lines,
just translate so that none
of them go through the origin.
And then convert into
corresponding set of points.
And the nice thing
about this duality
is it preserves
incidence, meaning
if before I apply duality, I
have a point and a line that
are touching, then after apply
duality, I will have a line
and appointed are touching.
So that's great,
because in particular,
a three-way
intersection or a point
is on three lines will
convert into a line
that it goes through
three points.
And so we get a reduction
from here to here.
That's kind of like magic.
But it works, essentially
because-- well,
if you think of a line over here
as just a pair of coordinates,
usually written a,
b, then we're just
taking essentially a dot product
between those two things.
It's a plus 1.
But it doesn't matter
which one was the point
and which one was the line.
So that's very convenient.
And you can use that to
convert a lot of line problems
into point problems.
I won't mention k sum very much.
But obviously, the d dimensional
versions here are d plus 1 sum
hard.
So that's these are sort of the
more geometric versions of k
sum.
So let's do some more problems.
Next one's called a separator.
So let's say we're given n
line segments in the plane,
is there a line
that separates them
into any two non-empty groups?
And that line is not allowed to
intersect any of the segments.
So you're not allowed to split
a line segment into two parts.
You just want to partition the
line segments into a left chunk
and a right chunk.
So there's actually two
versions of this problem.
The first version allows half
infinite rays as segments.
And then you can assume that
all the segments are horizontal.
So I think that pretty
clearly expresses it.
But we can in
particular think that we
are reducing from GeomBase.
We had this setup.
We have points on three lines.
We want to know whether
there's a line that
passes through them.
So I'm just going to take
the complement essentially
of those lines, emit tiny
intervals wherever I had points
before.
And now there will be a
separating line, if and only
if, the original points
have a line through them.
If you make these
tiny enough, you
won't be able to do
anything else-- oops, yeah--
or you could just split
them into 1/3, 2/3, yeah.
I definitely need here that
it's a non-horizontal line.
Thanks.
Now this requires having
these half infinite rays.
Otherwise you could
make a line like this.
So you're not allowed to
do that if these goes off
to infinity, then you'd
be cutting those rays.
OK, so maybe you
consider that reasonable.
Maybe not.
Depends on the application.
If you don't consider half
infinite things reasonable,
you can replace them with
some vertical segments.
You build this little
box, essentially
a box like a pinwheel pattern.
So there's no way
to cut it up except
to go through the center.
So two versions-- version one,
we allow half infinite things.
And every segment is horizontal.
Version two, horizontal
and vertical segments
are all finite length.
We'll use this version to
reduce from a bunch of times.
Or we will follow this kind
of reduction essentially.
OK, next problem.
OK, next problem is
called strips cover box.
I like these names of problems.
They're pretty clear.
In fact, they're so
clear, here's a figure.
We have a box, which means
axes align rectangle.
And I have strips.
Strips are-- I take
two parallel lines
and take the lines
in between them.
All these parallel lines between
here and here-- that's a strip.
So I'm given n strips.
I'm given a box.
I want to know whether
there's an empty part
or whether it covers.
AUDIENCE: Can you [? use ?]
angle or just strips?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, sorry,
the strips are placed.
I give you two lines
for each strip.
And I mean the region
in between them.
They're on the plane.
You can't slide them around.
That would be a
coverage problem.
It's pretty easy.
I just want to compute
whether there's
any point in here is not hit
by any of the given strips.
I should mention, all
of these problems,
except where I
say otherwise, can
be solved in quadratic time.
And so this is showing that
that's essentially tight.
So you can solve this
problem by computing
the arrangement of these
lines in quadratic time
and checking all the
cells, whether they're
in all the strips.
So that's not hard.
But the claim is you
can't do any better
than n squared if you
believe the 3SUM conjecture.
And the reduction
is essentially this.
But I'm going to
modify it a little bit.
So remember, I rotated this
90 degrees for a reason,
because I wanted to use a
particular kind of duality.
The construction is going
to be the dual of this.
But remember, here, the goal is
to find the line that does not
hit any of these segments.
And the segments are vertical.
Or they might be infinite,
half infinite rays.
OK, so I'm going to
start from there.
And then I'm going to dualize,
using a different dualization.
This is probably
the most popular one
in computational geometry.
I think because everyone
remembers y equals mx plus b.
And so there's the
obvious conversion
between a point, which has
b and m, to a line, which
is mx plus b.
You could argue
about which is which,
but I think this
is the more common.
So what this means is
I start with a point.
The y-coordinate determines
the slope of my line.
And the x-coordinate determines
the y-intercept of my line.
It's b.
And you can also convert
in the other direction.
I don't think we'll
need to be here.
And that will work for
all non-vertical lines.
This will not represent
vertical lines.
In case you're curious, if
you want vertical lines here
or if you want lines going
through the origin here,
you need points in infinity.
That's the projective
thing here.
But we don't need that here.
Because we're just going
to take these points
and convert each of them
to corresponding lines.
So this is a segment,
I'm going to get
an infinite number
of points-- sorry,
there's an infinite
number of points here.
So I'm going to convert into
an infinite number of lines.
That's actually
OK, because these
points all I have the
same-- sorry-- opposite.
I really want the x-coordinate
to m and the y-coordinate
to be b for this picture
to be the right picture.
So all these points have
the same x-coordinate.
So when I convert
them into lines,
they all have the same slope.
And they'll also be
right next to each other.
Namely, they will be a strip.
Isn't that cool?
So when you do this
dualization, a vertical segment
becomes a strip.
I think the fancy
word would be here
you have a pencil of points.
And you convert that into
a pencil of parallel lines.
A pencil of parallel
lines is strip.
Pencil just means like
a continuous family.
Now here, these
guys are infinite.
So it's going to be a
strip that it goes off
to infinity on one end.
That's a half plane.
So if we have a
ray, vertical ray,
that's going to convert
into half plane.
Half planes aren't
allowed, so we're
going to have to do
something with them.
But there's only six of them.
There's three down
here and three up here.
And we also haven't defined
what our target rectangle is.
But at this point
what we would like
to say-- so let's see, what
would it correspond to a line
here?
Notice, the line will
never be vertical.
What would be a
line that happens
not to hit any of these things?
In the dual, that
line maps to a point.
And so that's
saying that there is
a point that is not covered
by any of these strips or half
planes.
So we want to know whether
the union of these things
is the entire plane.
So it's not quite the problem
we wanted to reduce do.
But it's not hard to fix it.
We essentially just need to
make a retake a really big
rectangle.
And then there'll be an
empty point in there,
if and only if, there was
a line in this problem.
How big does the
rectangle have to be?
Well, conveniently, these
half planes essentially
narrows down to a hexagon.
So you have six of them.
It might be less than a hexagon.
But I'll just draw six.
And we're saying all of
this stuff is covered.
All the things
outside the hexagon
are covered by
those half planes.
So really it's just
a matter whether this
has any empty points.
So take the bounding
box of that hexagon.
That's my box.
And now I don't have to worry
about half planes anymore.
I can restrict them.
I can just say,
oh, well, now this
is a strip, which
covers-- in particular,
I need to cover this
part of the rectangle.
I no longer need to
go off to infinity.
So now, I have a bunch of
finite strips and a finite box.
And it's just a matter
of whether that thing has
any empty parts.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, there will be
an empty point, if and only
if the original thing
had a yes answer.
So they will cover, if and only
if, if you have a no answer.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Just nomenclature--
can have word [INAUDIBLE]
that thing you just
put on the right,
because it's actually a
special case of what you call
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
right, so what they say
is this a reduction
from GeomBase, mimicking
the proof of separator 1.
Yeah, I don't have
a name for it.
Sorry.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, this duality
also preserves incidence.
I think it's a slightly
perturbed version
of the regular
projector duality.
It is also a projected
duality in a sense,
but with an extra Mobius
transformation thrown in
or something.
But those also
preserve incidence.
Yeah, we obviously need that.
OK so to make this a little
more usable-- I mean,
strips can be nice.
We'll use it in some situations.
But geometers tend to like
to think about triangles.
So we can also convert this
into whether bunch of triangles
cover a given triangle.
Basically, so here we
are going to reduce
from strips covering a box.
We start with a box.
And we're going to convert
that-- we'll draw on top of it
so it's a little
clearer-- I'm going
to take a really big triangle,
which contains that box.
But then we'll triangulate
the exterior right here.
And add those triangles
to my covering collection.
So all of this stuff
is covered for free.
And so now what remains-- in
order to cover this triangle,
I just need to cover this box.
OK so, that's one part of it.
And then the other thing
is that we're given strips.
So if I have a strip-- actually,
do I have a figure for this?
No-- if I have a strip in
the original problem, which
looks something like
this, I really only
care about the portion of a
strip that hits the box here.
So I will just
triangulate that part
and say those triangles
are in my set.
And then those triangles are
going to cover this triangle.
The red triangles will
cover the red triangle,
the big red triangle, if and
only if the white strips cover
the white rectangle.
Pretty easy-- all we
need is that these
have constant complexity
so we're not blowing
up more than a constant factor.
Note here all of these
smaller triangles
are contained inside
the big triangle.
So you can even
assume that these guys
are contained in this guy.
We'll use that at some
point-- possibly very soon.
So next problem.
Hole in union-- I give
you a bunch of triangles.
I take their union.
I want to know whether that's
a simply connected polygon
or whether it has a
hole in the center.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Almost the
same as this problem.
I do is to do a
little bit of work,
because maybe you'd-- actually,
pretty much that reduction will
work fine, as long as the outer
triangle is strictly bigger
than the strip, then I'll always
have these outer red things,
which make a region.
And then there'll
be a hole in there,
if and only if the rectangle
is not fully covered.
So I just did to enlarge
that outer triangle slightly.
Then I have proof that
this is 3SUM hard.
Done.
Here, we're also using that
the red triangles are contained
inside the big red triangle.
We don't go outside and possibly
make a hole in some other way.
OK, another easy one--
triangle measure.
I give you a bunch of triangles.
What is the area of their union?
Well, it's going to be the
area of the big triangle,
if and only if the big
triangle's covered.
So this is a reduction from
triangle covers triangle.
OK, easy.
Here's a somewhat different
problem-- point covering.
So here I'm given a bunch
of half planes, n of them.
I want to know is there
a k-way intersection?
You can think of
this as a version
of two-dimensional
linear programming.
So this is all in 2D.
You're given a bunch of
linear inequalities, which
are half planes.
You want to know-- not
can I satisfy all them,
maybe that's not possible,
but can I satisfy at least k
of them?
So this is for approximating
linear programming.
There a lot of algorithms
for doing that.
You can do this
in quadratic time.
But the claim is you
can't do it better
unless if you believe
the 3SUM conjecture.
OK, so this is-- I don't
have a figure-- no.
So we're going to reduce
from strips cover box.
So we're given a bunch--
this figure again--
we're given a bunch of strips.
We're given a rectangle.
We want to convert that whether
the whole thing intersects
to whether there's
a k-way intersection
between infinite strips
on one side, half planes.
So here's what I'm going to do.
If I have a strip--
I should maybe really
draw it this way--
bunch of parallel lines,
finite segment of them.
But the lines are
infinite in this is
direction and this direction.
I'm going to convert that into
the complement, a common trick
here.
So we have half plane over here.
And we have a half
plane earlier.
Obviously, you cannot be
in both of these at once,
because they're disjoint.
So the best you can hope for
is to be in one of them, which
means you're not here.
And remember, the
whole question here
is whether there's a point that
is not in any of the strips.
So you're going
to get one point--
you're going to get a score
of 1 if you're here or here.
You're going to get a score
of 0 locally if in the region
that's already covered.
Now we also need to represent
the rectangle in some way.
So if I'm given a box.
Draw this line, this line,
this line, and this line.
And the half planes
I want are the ones
that contain the rectangle.
So the idea is you're going to
get four bonus points if you're
in the rectangle.
And now the question is-- I'm
going to set k to be n plus 4.
I want to know are there
any points that are
in n plus 4 of the half planes.
To do that, you have
to be in all four
of these-- in other
words, in the box--
and in one of these
for every strip,
because you can't be in both.
It's just to achieve
that score of n plus 4.
So that means you're
exterior to all the strips,
but inside the rectangle.
So that's the same problem.
Cool.
Next problem is a
visibility problem.
So we've got a couple
of visibility problems.
Both of these problems
are about something
called weak visibility.
If you have two geometric
objects, a and b,
they are strongly
visible to each other,
if every point over here can
see every point over here,
meaning the visibility line
doesn't cross anything else.
But what we're
talking about here's
weak visibility,
which says there's
some point over here which
can see some point over here.
So I want to know, say, given
two segments, whether there's
some point here, some
point here, where
if I draw the connecting
visibility line,
there's no other
segment blocking it.
So this is a.
And this is b.
This would be an example
where a and b-- well, they
do weakly see each other,
because there's that pair.
So given n segments,
you can construct
what's called a
visibility graph, which
is all of these things
in quadratic time.
If I want to know
whether this segment can
see another segment in this
weak sense, that's 3SUM hard.
Here's the proof.
It's exactly the same thing,
just add two segments.
This segment can
see that segment,
if and only if there's a line.
There are so many fun
little things you can do.
But these are problems
that a lot of people
have thought about.
And they're always
wondering, can we
do better than quadratic?
Now we know they're all sort
of in the same bucket-- almost.
OK, here's another problem.
So the problem is I give you
a bunch of triangles in 3D.
And let's see, and maybe I
give you a point up here.
And I want to know whether
that point can weakly
see a given triangle.
And here all the
triangles are horizontal.
Make it nice and simple.
And it is possible to
solve this, I think,
in n squared log n time--
maybe n squared time.
You can construct the visibility
graph here in n squared,
because they're all horizontal.
So I'm given this point.
I want to know can
it see any of t.
Or is it completely
blocked by these triangles?
Sound familiar?
If we put that point way
up near or at infinity,
depending on what you
allow me-- near infinity
will be enough--
this will essentially
be orthographic projection
of these triangles
onto this triangle.
And it's a question
whether these triangles
cover this triangle.
So this is a reduction from
triangles cover triangle
to visible triangle.
Pretty easy, just put
all these guys really
close, slightly
different z-coordinates
so they're not overlapping,
and put the point far away.
So visible triangle
is 3SUM hard.
All right, let's do
some motion planning,
robot motion planning-- first in
2D-- so planar motion planning.
I give you a segment.
That's the robot.
And I have-- so this
is the special arm,
the robot-- then I have various
obstacles, which the robot is
not allowed to penetrate.
I give you a starting
position for the robot.
And I give you a target
And want to know can I go from
here to here by some motion?
And motion we'd allow
rotations and translations.
So can I slide
this robot somehow
through this obstacle
course, in here, just
some parallel parking, whatever.
You can do lots of tricks
to get from A to B.
This problem can be
solved in quadratic time.
Most 2D motion planning
problems with just rotation
and translation can be
sold in n squared time.
And that's tight,
because of this.
We build these frames, which
are large enough that it
doesn't concern the robot.
The robot's big
enough that it's going
to have to simultaneously
pierce all three lines here.
And we're done.
OK, great.
All this build up for
very simple proofs.
Cool, one more.
AUDIENCE: Is that one
actually quadratic time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can
solve this in quadratic time.
Cubic is obvious.
There are three
degrees of freedom.
But I think, in
fact, quadratic time.
That's claim in the paper.
I haven't studied motion
planning algorithms
for a while.
So I don't know
exactly how it goes.
But in general, constant
dimensional motion planning
with constant numbers of objects
can solved in polynomial time.
But you can debate
about the constants,
which do matter here.
I think the claim is
tightness for that one.
Here's another one which can be
solved in-- their claim here,
they say n squared
log n they say.
We can probably get n squared,
but n squared log n is enough.
It's a particular version
of 3D motion planning.
So we are given a
vertical segment.
That's our robot.
We're going to have triangles.
Those are our obstacles,
because triangles
we can make polyhedra.
In this case, all the triangles
will lie in horizontal planes.
And the segment position
will be vertical.
And here you're only
allowed translation.
With translation and rotation,
you could also do this.
But they restrict
to translation only,
because there they can get
a almost quadratic time
algorithm.
With rotation you have to
add a couple of factors of n
probably.
But this version, they can
solve in n squared log n.
And it's 3SUM hard by
similar kind of structure
to the triangles
covering triangle.
Mainly, we build this cage--
the triangles aren't shaded in.
But there's basically a
triangle of triangles here,
and a bunch of them.
The segment is a unit length.
And so there's this many
to subdivide the space.
They call this a cage.
All of these triangles
live in horizontal planes.
There's no way for this
vertical robot with translation
only to get out.
It's too long.
And so the starting
configuration
is going to be up here.
The destination is
going to be down here.
And in the middle
triangle here, we're
going to put a whole bunch
of triangles like this.
So just squish this down.
Put them all in here.
And you're going to be able
to penetrate if and only
if there's a blank spot.
End of this paper.
I think we covered almost
all of these proofs.
We started with the base
problems, 3SUM, 3SUM prime,
GeomBase, two
versions of separator,
which we weren't directly
reducing from but we mimicked
a zillion times.
We had the degeneracy
over here, strips
covering a box,
triangles covering
a triangle, hole in the
union, visible triangle.
Those are actually all
identical to each other.
You could reduce
in all directions.
We talked about point cup.
This was the linear programming.
Motion planning,
3D motion planning
happen to reduce here instead
of there, and visibility.
Cool.
Lot of fun, little
reductions, and it
gives you a flavor for n
squared hard-ish problems.
AUDIENCE: Are there
restrictions at all?
PROFESSOR: I think all
the restrictions are open.
I mean, you'd have to check
all the paper since 1995.
But definitely in that
paper, they're open.
And I haven't heard of any--
there isn't a ton of work
going the other direction.
But it would differently
nice to, especially
if 3SUM-- it builds more if
3SUM is the right problem,
if you can do reductions
in both directions.
I want to show you a
couple more-- I'll show you
one more reduction, which
relates to a problem
to be proved was strongly
NP complete at some point
way back when.
This is about
fixed angle chains.
You have this kind
of linkage structure.
These are rigid bars.
These are rigid angles.
But you can still twist
one segment around another.
So it preserves the angles
and the edge lengths.
And so if I give you
a structure like this,
I want to know if I
spin along this edge,
if I take all this
stuff and rotate it out
of plane around this edge,
does it hit anything?
Or can it go all the way around?
What about this edge?
This is a polynomial time
fixed angle chain problem.
I want to know for every edge,
which one's spinning causes
a collision.
In fact, if I just want to
know whether these guys cause
a collision, because if
they do, a plus b equals c.
I think that's maybe clear
enough with your negative B/2
in the middle.
In this case, we've
shifted-- the A,
B, C is the x-coordinate
in this structure.
And these are candidate
foldings here where we miss,
here we collide.
We separated things
out by taking
every item of a, subtracting a
huge number from it to put it
over here, and every item
of c, adding a huge number.
And because we're in
the 3SUM prime problem,
we know we get
one item for each,
so adding and subtracting
and matching huge number
will preserve all 3SUM
pairs, 3SUM triples.
So that let's us separate
out this picture.
And then you just have to check
this reflection corresponds
to adding in the right
way, because of negation we
divided by 2.
That's it.
So that's another.
And there are a bunch
of other problems,
like if I give you
two polygons, I
want to know whether I
can translate this polygon
to fit inside that polygon.
That's also 3SUM hard.
Proof is a little bit messy,
so I don't have it here.
Let me mention me another more
recent use of 3SUM conjecture
is some non-quadratic
lower bounds.
So we're still going to
assume the 3SUM conjecture,
but we're going to prove
that a problem requires
some time other than n squared.
So here are two problems
where this has been done.
These are graph
problems, which is cool,
because everything
we've seen so far
has been a geometric problem.
So the weighted,
undirected graph,
I want to know whether
there's a three cycle,
also called a triangle,
of given weight.
So I want to know, for example,
is there triangle weight of 0.
This can be done in
polynomial time, obviously.
And the lower bound says is
the number of edges to the 1.5,
instead of 2 or however you
want to think about this,
minus epsilon.
This is Mihai Petrescu.
What he says is this problem,
finding this in this much time,
is 3SUM hard, meaning
if this is possible,
then 3SUM could be solved
in sub-quadratic time.
So there's a gap between
this bound and 3SUM bound,
introduced by the reduction.
Here's another fun problem.
Here we're given an unweighted
graph, undirected graph.
And we just want to
find e triangles.
Just list them form me please or
tell me there aren't that many.
You cannot do that in any better
than e to the 4/3 minus epsilon
times if you believe
the 3SUM conjecture.
So these are both 3SUM
hard in a different sense
from what we were using before.
Before it was
quadratic quadratic.
With graphs, also
there's v verses e.
But neither of
these are quadratic
no matter how you slice them.
So there are different.
So there are a small number
of pounds of that form.
And that's kind of interesting
and relatively hot area.
So a few people are
thinking about that.
In particular, there's been
a recent surge of interest
in thinking about
graph problems.
Now for graph
problems, there isn't
a ton of work
relating 3SUM, which
is a very arithmetic
problem to graph problems,
but this is the
beginning of that.
But there are some
other problems
which people think are hard.
So let me give you some of them.
Diameter-- so here we're given
a weighted, undirected graph.
I want to know-- so delta v,
w-- this is like CRLS notation.
This is the weight
of the minimum weight
path from v to w.
And I want to know the
max overall v to w.
What is the longest
shortest path?
That's diameter.
Conjecture-- no V to
the 3 minus epsilon.
So here there's a lot of
interest around cubic problems,
because this
problem seems cubic.
Another closely related problem
is all pair shortest paths.
I want to know delta of
v, w for all v and w.
This is, of course, a harder
problem than diameter.
Also, this conjecture
implies conjecture over here.
This one's a little more famous.
The all pairs shortest path
conjecture is that you cannot
solve this in truly
sub-cubic time.
There are, again,
poly log improvements.
But you cannot beat-- we
don't know how to beat by a v
to the epsilon factor, n
to the epsilon factor over
the standard algorithm, which
should be Floyd Warshall,
the triply nested loop.
Relax every edge n times is
the standard cubed algorithm.
For sparse graphs
you could do better.
For dense graphs, the claim
is that's the best you can do.
And so there's a bunch of
problems that are all pair
shortest path hard.
There are some problems
that are diameter hard.
Being diameter hard is
a little bit stronger.
Obviously, diameter
can reduce to all pairs
shortest paths via now we want
a sub-cubic reduction, something
n to the 3 minus epsilon
time instead of n
to the 2 minus epsilon.
You can reduce diameter to
all pairs shortest paths.
Big open problem is whether you
could reduce all pairs shortest
paths to diameter.
But you can reduce
all pairs shortest
paths to some cool problems.
I have an image of
some reductions.
So negative triangle-- is there
a triangle of negative weight?
Over here we wanted a
triangle of weight exactly 0.
That helps you
find things faster.
Over here we just want a
triangle of negative weight.
There's more options for those.
Finding that is all pairs
shortest paths hard.
You can reduce all
pairs shortest path
that problem-- kind of crazy.
And here, the reduction
is not a single--
or a constant number
of call reductions
like we've been doing.
This has a huge output.
This only has a
yes or no output.
So this reduction's
a little bit crazy.
But basically you take
the sum over all calls
for this reduction.
And it just has to work
out that if you could solve
negative triangle and
sub-cubic time, then you
could also solve all
pairs shortest path
in sub-cubic time.
So if you take the
sum of the n primes
to the power 3
minus epsilon, this
should work out to
n to the 3 minus
epsilon over the different
the different calls you
make to the negative triangle.
So it's a weaker notion
of reduction, which
lets you prove these things.
Kind of a big innovation
from just-- this one
hasn't even published yet.
It will be in [? Sodo ?] 2015.
It's on the archive now.
And there been a few papers
over the last few years doing
these kinds of reductions.
Actually the
negative triangle one
is from an older paper
by Vassilevska Williams
and Williams.
It's a husband and
wife team, Stanford.
OK, some more problems, radius--
for vertex v, the radius
around v is how big a ball
do need to grow in order
to cover all the vertices.
I want to know what's the
farthest vertex w from v.
And then the radius
of the graph is
what is the best such vertex
that minimizes the radius,
the vertex.
So closely related to this.
But it is equivalent
to negative triangle.
Both of these are-- this
is a-- well, OK, of course,
you could reduce negative
triangle to-- well,
it's not so obvious.
You can reduce radius to
all pairs shortest paths,
because you have all the deltas.
You can compute that
max-min in quadratic time.
So that means all these problems
are equivalent to each other
up to sub-cubic reductions.
OK, median is another
problem-- very similar.
I just replace this
max with a sum.
So that's some other kind
of central located vertex.
That's median.
And that's also equivalent
to all these problems.
So there's a growing
list of problems
that are in this
sort of cubic space.
All the problems are
conjectured to be cubic.
And a lot of them are
equivalent to each other,
though there's this
divide between diameter
and all pairs shortest path.
There are some bounds,
assuming strong ETH.
So if you have strong
ETH, then there's
no e to the 2 minus
epsilon algorithm.
This is not quite what we want.
We want to v to the
3 minus epsilon.
This is a statement
about sparse graphs.
You can beat this
for dense graphs.
For sparse graphs
this is interesting.
This is for the worst case
relationship between v and E.
So you get somethings like this.
You get this even if you
allow some approximatability.
But we still don't have a way to
actually prove this conjecture.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since you haven't
said anything about it,
I assume that 3SUM
and this world, there
is no bridge between them.
PROFESSOR: I believe
there's no bridge currently.
This is the closest thing.
And they do seem similar.
And also here we have cubic.
There we have quadratic.
So maybe you can do it.
Maybe with 5 SUM you
could show some relation.
I don't know.
But there's no such theorem yet.
These problems sound very
similar to these problems,
in particular listing a
bunch of negative triangles
is just as hard as finding one.
And so there's some
similarity to over here.
But the constraint on the
triangles is different.
Here we want negative ones.
Here any triangle or
triangle of 0 weight.
So it's an interesting space.
It's still very ongoing.
All of these things-- this
stuff, and this stuff--
is all within the
last four years.
So it'll be interesting
to see how it develops.
But these are the
current approaches
to understanding n
squared, n cubed,
and sort of the low end
of the polynomial spectra.
I think it's pretty
interesting, but also where
we know the least and have
the fewest general techniques
for proving things.
3SUM is a little
more established.
And there's a bunch of proofs
like the one you've seen-- not
too many out there actually.
But they're quite accessible.
This stuff is still,
I think, converging.
But very exciting
things, relating
all these algorithmic problems
to each other and kind
of a nice way for us to end.
This is my last
lecture for 6890.
And the next two classes are
lectures by [? Acosis ?] about
how [? arithmic ?] game theory
in a class called PPAD and PPAD
hardness, which is
its own universe,
but around economic game
theory and very cool stuff.
He is the expert on it
and he's a professor here,
so he graciously agreed
to do two lectures on it.
Should be fun.
I'm looking forward to it.
Thanks.